I'm very excited to
have a Scott
give a guest lecture today
with us.
So, Scott Reed, he's a founding member
of the generalist embodied agent
research lab at Nvidia.
And before that, he studied generative
models and generalist agents
for 8 years at Google DeepMind.
For example, he's also very well known
for leading um
the Gato paper, generalist
>> [clears throat]
>> agent paper
a few years ago.
And
he completed his PhD at the University
of Michigan in 2016
under Honglak Lee. And
yeah,
we are very excited to hear about your
talk on latest research, Scott. Please
give him a warm welcome.
All right, thanks thanks for the intro
and thanks for having me here. I'm very
excited to speak to you all.
And that I'll begin. So, the talk I'll
give is about
backbones for robot learning and the
major choices that we can make here and
emerging paradigms. So, VLAs, world
action models, work from scratch. What's
the right backbone we should use for
embodied agents?
First, a little bit about me.
So, I'm from Michigan.
This is actually just really the
intro blur, but yeah. So, at DeepMind 8
years doing work on generative models
and generalist agents. And
last 2 years
on the gear team led by Jim Fan and
Yuka. And
there's a family and a new guy there
just joined. And yeah, that's me.
So, what do I mean by backbone? So, for
this talk, I mean the architecture that
encodes robot sensor data,
camera, as appropriate, and also the
language instructions.
Encode all of those things into some
shared representation that can be used
for action prediction. So, this
backbone, it determines not just how the
policy runs at inference time, but how
it's able to soak up knowledge during
pre-training and transfer that to
downstream tasks of the robot.
And the major choices here
that can be made is one just go from
scratch, just train some visual
architecture
just on your robot data, which could
make sense
if you have a lot of it.
Or if you just care about some narrow
task on a particular embodiment. It's
not very open-ended.
Over the past 5 or 10 years, the
dominant paradigm has actually been more
to use pre-trained foundation models
instead, or at least initialize from
them. And the major choices here would
of course be to use VLM like a vision
language model, which might have been
used for things like visual question
answering.
Or
to the emerging paradigm is to use video
models. Or there's different names for
them. People Some people are calling
them world models, but basically the the
lineage of these things is from video
generation.
And in turn that into a backbone. Of
course,
video diffusion models have been
around for
a long time now, a few years, but I
think only recently have reached a stage
of maturity and in terms of the quality
and also in terms of the architecture
that would support them being a backbone
for robotics and other embodied agents.
So, the agenda, I'll first give
brief survey of VLAs and have some
commentary on those, and then world
action models, and then discuss train
from scratch both the historical
perspective and some more recent
exciting developments there. And then we
can conclude with
discussing the future directions and
have some Q&A.
So,
what are what are the
key papers in VLAs?
So, of course, we have
robot transformer series like RT-2,
OpenVLA,
the Pi models, Pi-0, Pi-0.5, Pi-0.6, the
group models we did at Nvidia
focus more on
humanoids. TRI's
large behavior model, and then Gemini
and many others.
These are just the ones I'm most
familiar with. And the key principles
here, the good things about them are
it puts everything into a a unified
modality.
They tend to support cross embodiment
well.
You can just directly fine-tune VLM to
generate control tokens. There's a lot
of diversity here in terms of how they
represent actions. Some use discrete,
some use
continuous and do diffusion or flow
matching. And the great thing about them
is that they can leverage internet scale
data
for reasoning and grounding. And in
terms of the generalization, they there
is some evidence that they outperform
from scratch imitation learning.
By by training on multi-task and
multi-embodiment, they actually are more
data efficient and have higher top-end
performance than training from scratch
on a single task or single embodiment.
So, what do the architectures look like?
So, I'll just show OpenVLA first cuz
that's the simplest one. And then people
may be familiar with this.
Basically, you have some pre-trained any
vision encoder like Dino or CLIP or both
to encode language and and vision. And
the instructions are encoded with some
pre-trained language model. And this
whole thing might be frozen at least at
first, and then you learn to detokenize
that into actions. In this case, the
actions are just discrete discretized
with binning.
And then they'll later
be detokenized into the continuous
values when you actually want to run the
policy. So, this is just a very simple
architecture that actually turns out to
work
quite well.
There are fancier things you can do
like the
Pi models have both a discrete and
continuous
action prediction.
So, they have this thing called fast
tokenizer. They have separate braces to
encode the tokens. So, that
VLM can be co-trained with both language
tasks like predicting subtasks,
while at the same time predicting
actions.
This turns out to be a great thing for
pre-training because
it turns out that if if you had just
tried to co-train directly predicting
discrete language tokens and then also
back propagating flow matching or
diffusion gradients through your VLM,
this this would destroy your VLM
weights. And so, you would lose things
you would lose properties such as
language following. There might be ways
to do it if you carefully train in
stages,
but there's always a risk of
catastrophic forgetting when once you
just naively try to co-train on VLM
language
prediction tasks and robot action
prediction. So, by
doing everything
with discrete tokens,
it open up a lot of options for how to
do the pre-training and to end up with
better representations
in your VLM for control.
However, there is still a benefit to
having this like separate diffusion or
flow matching action expert because
in some cases when you decode your
discrete
action tokens, you may have decoding
errors. This is one of the problems with
that. And you can imagine that this
could cause safety issues. Like what if
you you know, if if your
decoded action is
somehow undefined and it's an error
and it just generates some kind of
default position target for your robot
arm. You could imagine the arm just
flinging out and doing something really
dangerous.
So, so for both safety reasons and
probably also for
performance reasons, it's still good to
have this
flow matching or diffusion action expert
because you'll never have decoding
errors there.
And
there's a lot of other VLAs with
diffusion decoders. So,
like Pi, all the group models. This is
the TRI.
They call it large behavior model. I
think it's just an alternative name for
VLA. I also like large behavior model as
a name.
And this one also takes pre-trained VIT
like image and language. They have a
simplified architecture here where
actually they're just concatenating the
VIT image tokens and the language tokens
and going straight to the
VIT. That actually works
surprisingly well, at least on their
suite of tasks. And the great thing
about this paper, everyone should read,
they do a really rigorous study of like
not just wishful thinking, but really
examining
does multi-task pre-training
VLA style actually improve downstream
task performance? Does it improve
data efficiency and top-end performance?
And they find that it does
pretty pretty significantly. But they
had to do very very careful
very careful analysis due to the
difficulty of real robot evaluation.
They didn't do things like double-blind
evaluation. So, you take pairs of
policies,
have evaluators actually not know which
one is which one, and compare them
head-to-head in the same robot at the
same time.
And doing careful statistical analysis
to make sure that the results were
statistically significant. Um and yeah,
the findings do back up a lot of the
intuitions that people had about VLAs,
but it's great that someone actually did
this very rigorously. And I think
there's a lot of great lessons in that
paper.
Um and so here's some of the
cool demos that I find inspiring from uh
VLAs VLA era. So, like high difference
states, the busy the fine model with RL
uh post training, making special drinks
for like
over an hour, almost an hour. Uh I found
that really, really impressive. Um
here's another one from Nvidia.
Uh it's called Ego Scale. Um this was
built on the uh root animal 5
architecture and they used um a lot of
um
actually human egocentric data with hand
tracking.
Um
And uh that data in particular is what I
think made this recipe work very well
on. And um so V- so VLAs can control a
manual parallel jaw gripper, they can
control like humanoid hands really well.
Um
they can also control um humanoids when
you combine them with a whole body
controller. So, the VLAs are now finding
applications in all kind of different
robot form factors. And um
yeah, starting to be mature as a model
class.
So, what are the strengths?
Um
you get semantic grounding from
pre-training. Um
new new task learning is data efficient
compared to going from scratch.
And there's supposed to be predictable
improvement as you scale the model and
the data, assuming you have you know,
high quality data to scale.
And there's some evidence of cross-task
and cross-embodiment transfer, but um I
would say it's uh far from solved. Um
there are some weaknesses
like
the prediction and reasoning are
happening in your
uh action space, which might be
language, might be
um
the continuous space where you're doing
diffusion.
Um
that might not be the right place to do
reasoning about physics or
uh control actually. It may may
[clears throat] not be the optimal way
to do that.
The action representation is typically
bolted on in some way after
pre-training. And there's always a risk
of catastrophic forgetting during
fine-tuning. Um this is especially in
data islands. Um
we try we do to the
lack of lots of web-scale data for
robotics, we have this
intuition that we should just throw all
the robot data from different
embodiments together. Let's call it
cross-embodiment. Um but it's likely
that the the model just sees these as
completely separate islands that um from
which there's not much transferability
or that the transferability is is
limited due to the difference in
form and correlational structure
um in these subsets of data.
Um and the evidence for like zero-shot
distribution zero-shot generalization
out of distribution or to new
embodiments is is limited or
non-existent in my opinion for for um
contemporary VLAs anyways.
So, what is the emerging class of
policy uh models that um
have many people excited? Uh world
action models or video action models. Um
so, some popular um
instantiations that came out recently
would be Dream Zero, Cosmos Policy. Um
some older ones actually is the GR1, GR2
from um
ByteDance. Um
and probably a bunch more uh coming out
that have come out in recent
conferences. Um these are just ones I'm
mainly familiar with. And uh what's the
paradigm shift here? Um
we want to predict the world state in
pixels uh either before acting or
jointly with acting. Um and so we can do
prediction and reasoning in a much
richer space that may be more suitable
to
control.
Um
also, I would highlight that
the pre-training objective um may allow
the policy to just soak up a lot more
relevant information um during
pre-training than just action
prediction.
We can just squeeze a lot more juice out
of the data that way uh in my opinion
than we could if we were just predicting
um
uh actions only.
So, what do these architectures uh look
like? So, here's uh the Dream Zero
architecture. Um
we have there's going to be some VAE to
encode the uh
video frames into latents, um
concatenate them with action embeddings,
um conditions upon on language, um and
we have some causal a block causal uh
DiT so that um
th- this this allows us to have um
caching key caching during inference so
that we can have we can do efficient uh
sampling of frames and action uh when we
want to uh run the policy. Uh in Dream
Zero, we actually have some joint uh
flow matching uh
of both action and uh future uh chunk of
frames.
Um
Th- there so in actually in Dream Zero,
you can choose to jointly diffuse uh
both fully or and we have they have
something called Dream Zero Flash where
um you just do one step uh or two or two
steps where you don't completely
actually denoise the future vision chunk
and you just focus on the the action
chunk. And that actually turns out to be
to perform just as well. Um
so so um
among the different video-based
uh
video model-based policies, um there
there's a few different ways to get
actions. Some of them will actually
fully sample a roll out and then use
some inverse dynamics model to recover
the actions. Um some of them are doing
uh planning. Um
and some of them uh
just use the video uh prediction
pre-training um
as a pre-training technique and they
don't actually need to fully diffuse the
future observations uh during inference
time. And um
I think there's an interesting analogy
to reasoning models in in the VLAs like
um
we see something similar there where a
lot of the benefit from doing reasoning
is that you just did it during
pre-training. You learned a better
representation that way and you the best
thing to do probably still is doing
reasoning at inference time, but even if
you don't, having done it during
pre-training makes your model better.
Um gives you better representations. And
then something something similar is true
I would say for videos for video models.
Um another uh one that came out around
the same time was Cosmos Policy. Um
very similar idea, but with an
interesting um
difference is in addition to predicting
um just actions a- and images, future
images, they also diffused uh future
proprio and uh value. Um so, I think
this paradigm is actually quite
flexible. Um and maybe this paper could
even have a stronger claim to being a
proper world model. Um
because it's just modeling uh a more
complete um
set of things than in the world of uh
robots.
And the way that they their architecture
looks is also quite interesting. The
design choice they made was to encode uh
proprio to embed proprio and actions and
value into the image embedding space and
just tile it spatially. Um
so, that way from the perspective of the
diffusion models, everything is is uh
vision. You just have some uh
special types of
frames uh for for action, proprio, and
value in addition to the um
robot camera data. And the model just
figures it out um
as you know, as tend to do when you give
them enough data.
Um and also um
a very different paradigm that actually
came earlier was autoregressive world
action models like GR1 and GR2 from from
ByteDance. And these are like
interleaving models that interleave uh
language, robot state, uh image, and
just predict everything. And they also
have some uh pretty pretty encouraging
impressive results. Um
uh long before um
other other teams came to this uh
paradigm. And I I I I think this could
be scaled and pushed um
quite far as well.
Actually, this is more of the kind of
flavor of model that I uh worked on
previously. Um
of uh Gato, which is just one big tran-
transformer language model trained on
all the robot data. Just kind of have
some way of canonically serializing all
of your sensor data and camera data into
a flat sequence of tokens and model it
with a transformer. Uh they make some
clever design choices here and push it
way further in in robotics, but um it's
kind of that school of thought of like
one big transformer for everything
um into into a flat series of tokens. Um
I think that can also be pushed quite
far.
Um here's some uh web demos from uh
Dream Zero that I found uh pretty
impressive. Um the cool thing about
these is um no no none of these um
behaviors were in the robot training
data. Um
although it may have been shown by uh
humans in in the pre-training at some
stage uh of the video model. So, it can
do things like untying boxes, uh pulling
carts, pull a straw out of a cup, shirt
ironing. Um
I don't know if if it's really actually
ironing. It's it's not actually doing
ironing, it's going through the motions.
So, you can see how this can be pushed
further uh and hopefully um
become genuinely useful uh at some stage
of um development. So,
uh diving deeper into Dream Zero, um
we can look at the what the generated
videos look like. So, for here's like
untying the box. Um it's obviously not
pixel perfect, but it's generally uh
showing
um it's generally consistent with what
the robot actually does. Um what we tend
to observe with these models is that
performance um in terms of the sample
quality and the success rate scales with
model size. So, when we use like the 14
billion parameter when model, it was way
better than the 2B. And both for the
samples and the success rate. And doing
some failure analysis, we see most
failures stem from video generation
errors rather than action prediction.
So, whenever predict the video
predicted, that's what the policy ended
up doing. Um, and this suggests
something exciting, which is that
improvements to the video backbone can
directly translate to better when
performance. So, whenever we see holes
in the in the policy and the errors, um,
if we just kind of improve the video
[clears throat] model there, um,
we can expect that uh policy will
improve. And also, it doesn't
necessarily require that we have robot
data to fill in those gaps. It could be
uh human data. Um,
so um this gives us one
uh promising path forward in um
in robot learning. So, the strengths of
when uh I'd say that they naturally
learn some kind of intuitive physics
from pixels. And they give us a much
more scalable source of pre-training
data. If most of the juice is just
coming from predicting camera sensors,
we just need to give a lot of data from
cameras. Um, and it's embodiment
agnostic uh in a sense due to the
unified output space for prediction and
reasoning. Um, there's less of a
tendency towards data islands um because
everything shares the same form of
correlational structure that you're
predicting. Um, but they have some
weaknesses like they're very expensive
to sample compared to VLAs. Um, modeling
every pixel is probably overkill. I
mean, we're not doing it in space, we're
doing it in latent space, but it's still
it's a type of latent space that was
learned to compress pixels but still be
able to reconstruct them. Um, right? So,
you know, we're taking we're taking the
latent space of video prediction models
that ultimately have to produce
aesthetically appealing high visual
fidelity.
Um, that that still may be overkill for
robotics. And there's
um a lot of papers showing that you care
about just one domain like Minecraft,
for example,
you could train a much much more
compressed
uh tokenizer or VAE for just for that
space.
Um, and train a sequence model on that
which um generalizes well and is much uh
more compact and run a much faster. Um,
if we were to care about like really
open domain robotics,
um, it's not clear we can compress that
much, but um I do think that's a
promising area of like can we if we just
start doing control and we don't
ultimately care about generation, is
there some modification we can make to
these tokenizers or VAEs used by whens
that just compress them a lot? And
there's a lot of exciting research
happening. I think the answer is yes,
but uh we need some an approach that is
that is robust in general uh and kind of
plug and play. And I and then I think
that they'll drive a further cycle of
improvement in whens. Um, also context
length is currently limited in most
contained query approaches. Again,
there's tons of cool research happening
here. Um,
I think it's just a matter of making it
really simple um
for people to use um to and um
and scalable without without sacrificing
performance. Um,
so how do we how do we how do we extend
uh context length?
So, the third paradigm is uh training
things uh from scratch. Um, here's the
main papers that I think about in the um
robot policy from scratch genre. Um,
going way back in time to like the DQN
days, um, before the foundation model
era, like everyone just trained some
bespoke network on like one task. And of
course, people had the idea what if we
train one big network on all the data.
So, um, I would say Gato, Octo, RT-1 uh
are of this um concept. So, in Gato, um,
we even took like text and images and
the QA tasks along with Atari and
robotics and just tokenized everything
into one big transformer. And you can do
that um and you can do that with robots
as well, um, whether it's single
embodiment multitask like RT-1 or or or
many tasks like RTX um and Octo.
Um, there is this tendency to learn data
islands which limit the generalization.
I would say there's some generalization
in all of these, um, but but still
limited by the data island uh
phenomenon. And um we do tend to I think
of this approach we we do tend to hit a
limit of just how many um embodiments
how much data high quality data you can
get from a like a data consortium or
just like in my case harvesting all the
data I could from DeepMind sim agents
and a few robots. Um, it's it's kind of
bounded by like researcher time.
Um,
so what are the modern approaches to
like from scratch? So, really exciting
things happening with UMI, um, Universal
Manipulator Interface,
um, like uh Generalist AI and Sunday of
course and other companies. Um,
I just included just uh some for
examples.
Um,
they're doing large scale human based
pre-training. I think they said they
have like 500K hours something crazy
like that. Um,
so with these sensorized humans, if you
add sensors to the humans, you can um
gather really really high quality
really high quality demonstrations that
transfer directly to the robot.
Another approach is just to not even
have sensors but use cameras to um
to do annotation of data of like humans
um doing things in the wild. This is
Ego4D from DeepMind. We only had 20K
hours, um, but uh
it could easily be scaled uh way more.
And um with a small amount of like
sensorized data like 50 hours is a
viable amount as well. And like a tiny
amount of robot data, uh we see pretty
pretty impressive results. So, both of
these kind of approaches are showing
scaling law
uh type of behaviors where where you
just increase the human data, you you
see a a
a continuous decrease in the validation
loss and you see a
a a monotonic increase in the success
rate. So, both of these papers that take
a very different approach, but they're
both saying um with human data not not
scaling the data but scaling human data
which scales much better. Um,
from scratch can then actually work. And
so, you can think about training a
foundation model without without having
to uh chain yourself to either VLMs or
video models or anything. You can do
whatever architecture you want. The
architecture may not even matter.
Um,
so concluding thoughts and somewhat
tongue here. Uh what I'm really bullish
on these days is uh world action models
video action models for their um
generalization properties and also
scaling human data which could be
sensorized or only partially sensorized.
I think that putting these two together
will take robot learning uh a really
long way and I'm excited to see um great
work everyone does on this.
And thank you to everyone for having me
here and I think now I can pause for
some discussion.
>> [applause]
>> Hey. Uh so, you mentioned that you think
that predicting the latent space of a
VAE designed to like for video
generation might be overkill. Do you
think predicting the latent space of
like a Jeppa model or something like
that might be more efficient?
Yes, I think I think so. I think so. Um,
yeah, latent world models
um
are very promising direction. I don't
know if I would like make a big bet on
that on the right now because I think we
still need to fig we we don't know um
exactly what are the right features for
robotics. We have this intuition, many
of us have this intuition that pixels
are overkill, but at least they are
sufficient.
They they
um that there's probably a lot in there
that we don't need, but but we we don't
know exactly how like we don't know how
to cut it down to the minimal subset of
features that that are needed. So, yeah,
I I think Jeppa and other latent uh
world models are definitely the right
direction. Um,
but
yeah, it's it's it's un- unclear that
they've that they've solved it yet. I
think I think more research needs to be
done there.
Hi. Um, thank you for the presentation.
Um, you mentioned that um at some point
these video action models should get
better
with the quality of the video
generation.
Um, but maybe there's an alternative
conclusion which is that the action
conditioning doesn't work.
How do we ensure that it's not the
action conditioning but the quality of
the video model that is the problem?
Uh the action conditioning? Do you mean
like for if you're doing some kind of
roll out and you're doing planning with
the with the world model or how how do
you mean the action conditioning here?
>> the the slide showed that the action
prediction actually worked, but
>> Mhm. the generated video was bad. And
these were the failure cases.
So, the problem could be either that the
video the video model is bad or that the
action is out of distribution or not
well the video model is not well
conditioned on this action.
Yes, yes. We need to kind of decompose
these problems. There are cases Yeah, I
think there could definitely be cases
where the video is is perfect and the
model is just unable to uh
find the right action that explains that
video. Um,
but typically we saw um
when working on this paper that uh most
of the failures
um we can correlate we can correlate the
the the
task failure with the low quality video.
Like the video will actually show it the
the the
the robot tends to at least try to do
the gross motor actions that follow um
follow the video. But you can see with
the quality of these videos if there's
some kind of very very fine grained uh
manipulation,
Then
it may not that that information may
just not be in the video. So I think at
the very, very, very fine-grained
manipulation level, there is still
the problem of just generating actions,
which which can be disentangled from the
the
video generation itself.
I think as video models get higher and
higher quality, they'll capture more and
more fine-grained
motions. And I would expect like the
correlation between video failure and
action failure to to be even tighter.
Hello.
I have two questions. So, do you think
that simulation will be redundant and
that world models will be enough to
basically capture all of the world's
physics and dynamics? And that also RL,
so like online and offline RL on top
will like with scaling
not be necessary. So like you think it's
just like scaling issue and the current
architecture we have is enough to
capture everything. And also do you
think that video alone is sufficient?
Like you said sensorized human data. By
that do you just mean like Arya glasses
like capturing where the hand is or do
you also mean like tactile feedback? Do
you think that tactile can like force
can be completely inferred from the
video? Do you think we still need
hardware to collect that kind of human
data?
Yeah, a lot of great questions there.
I'll try to go through them one by one.
So for sim, it will sim be redundant.
I think not anytime soon. I I do think
that like neural-based sim will be
very helpful for manipulation and and
may displace some of the role of like
sim manipulation. Although I'm sure
there's a lot of people who would
disagree with me on that, but I think
like contact with manipulation and
deformables and this kind of thing like
it might be where
neural-based sim can shine. We can do
like learning in that neural simulator.
But for things like whole body control
on humanoids or
quadrupeds and this kind of thing, I
think
sims I doubt that sims are really going
anywhere. I mean just the
the efficiency of the human hand-crafted
sims is just so amazingly high that
and then the cost the expense of running
these world models is is so
expensive that um
I wouldn't expect them to overtake
uh
human-crafted sims for for those anytime
soon. But
who knows what what research will come
out on that next but yeah, I I think
there's a role for both sim and neural
sim for for for some time.
Other questions on like force sensing
and tactile.
Yes, I I think
when it comes to sensorized humans um
I do think we should collect at least
some amount of those. I don't know like
I
I think okay, I think yeah, so let's
keep your head this argument that for
for
language models. Do they have a world
model? He says, well, I mean if you are
training a model on enough of the entire
corpus of
English text or web text and you really
want to predict the next token with just
maximal
accuracy, implicitly in the model you
should have some world model of like how
to explain what's going to happen next,
which would require some deep
understanding maybe even of physics,
maybe even of things
that
you would think would require embodied
experience, but if you just drive down
the perplexity, if you just drive down
the the loss of this language model, a
better model would
sort of by construction have this world
model. So I think the same thing is even
more true for video prediction models
like things
all kind of forces that are not
explicitly in in the pixels may be
latent in the model if it's good enough
model at predicting those things.
There's all kind of correlates of those
forces in the pixels that you're
predicting.
So if you want to do a good enough job,
that video model must have those
features in them and you just need to
elicit those features. We need ways to
probe and elicit those features.
And so if that's true, I still think we
need a lot of sensorized
Do we have to sensorize humans and
collect data? But maybe only like
maybe several orders of magnitude less
than we need of the pixels.
Like like the Ego4D like the way they
did it
is
I think informative. Like they had 20k
hours of just in the wild with camera on
the head.
They only needed 50 with five like five
is tracking the wrist and Manus glove is
tracking the fingers.
And you can imagine like adding tactile
as well. Like probably that's that's
kind of what I would expect is like
the tactile is is there,
but only a small amount. And it's really
the point of it is like to elicit those
features that were already in the world
model that were kind of learned
from mostly from video.
>> [clears throat]
>> You talked about that you know, policy
performance will now scale with video
prediction performance for example and
then also with the scale of the data. Do
you think like the future of like
exciting robot policies will only be or
we will only see exciting policies from
companies in the future basically?
Because there's so much capital involved
in training all these
nice video models and collecting all
this data or what's the future going to
be?
No, I think that exciting things are
going to happen from academia and big
companies and small companies.
I think that
yeah, a lot of times great ideas come
from having experiences and yeah, I
think we we will we will see amazing
stuff including really high fidelity
cool interactive video models from labs
and companies of all scales, I think.
So GPU if you want to train backbones,
that takes a lot of GPU hours.
But there are also other problems that
you might be able to solve in robot
learning and
that require less GPU hours. So which
problems would you look at
if you are like more constrained as a
researcher?